spoiler-free this is a spoiler for your
review of the movie split I really have
to make that clear because I think
everyone's going to be talking about the
twist in this movie and I hate saying
that because that's such a cliche in
such a little tagline and stuff but I
really think they are um and if you got
the twisting I I so would you okay um
the the best way to talk about this for
me is just to talk through just what I
was thinking while going through the
movie again without giving anything away
so if you've seen the trailers you know
this is a Shyamalan film about a man who
kidnaps these three high school girls he
has multiple personalities you know not
just a couple I think wasn't like 23 or
something like that and he keeps going
on and on how he's going to bring out
the beast he's keeping them for the
beast and the Beast is in him and it
could grow really strong it can because
it's the power of all the identity
together you can do like superhuman
stuff like climb walls and shit like
that so that's the setup and I will not
reveal anything beyond that so when does
movie started I'm watching it and I saw
the preview I'm like okay this is easier
this is going to be one of those so bad
it's good movies and I was dealing with
it okay
I was actually there are those Shyamalan
isms kind of like how they're in the
visits um you know where it's like only
a person wouldn't say that or this one
after why didn't this character do that
you're kind of doing that but it's not
too distracting like you're with it okay
you still want to know what's going on
you want the people to get out okay um
and aside from one or two little quirky
scenes and things that don't make sense
you know it's your with it um and James
McAvoy is doing if I'm saying the name
right I hope I am he's doing for the
most part a good job it is very
over-the-top but it works it does work
and
in my opinion it's not quite to a point
where it's like oh come on guy you're
just going so crazy I mean he is but it
for me it worked well enough and I was
ready to laugh my ass off at this guy
you know I saw the trailer I went oh my
god it was going to be another you know
Mark Wahlberg in the happening or
something like that but he does okay and
the personalities for the most part are
believable and the film is legitimately
entertaining as it's going on and then
they kind of get to the end and the end
before the twist or anything else what's
just I'm watching I'm saying this is
getting way too silly this is getting
way too stupid why couldn't he stop at
step three is to go to four or five and
six you know why can't it just be five
people in an elevator and then you have
to go those extra steps was the devil
I'm thinking this is the devil thing all
over again uh and then it gets to the
very very end where they reveal the
twist and I did not see it coming and I
was really looking for it I'm like okay
I bet it's this or I bet this person is
that birdie and I'm legitimately looking
for it and then when they get to it I
literally went ah like I man
it totally caught me off guard and the
twist to this movie is either gonna make
it or break it for people people are
either gonna go bravo Bravo
you are amazing that holy crap that was
phenomenal or they're gonna say bull
fucking shit that is ridiculous what a
terrible filmmaker um so for me I liked
it I got sucked into that twist but
there is a major problem with the rest
of the film in my opinion again without
giving you away too much one of the
girls they go into her backstory and
they they give her again not
surprisingly the reveal pretty early
early on a tragic backstory and as it
goes on you see more and more what
is um and you know how there's a Captain
Planet episode where they're going to
talk about AIDS and you're just like
don't do a Captain Planet you're not
maybe another show can do this you
cannot you are not talented enough
that's kind of how I felt about this in
Shyamalan um Shyamalan has tackled dark
stuff before in both good and bad films
and there is it's kind of like you know
a like maybe a senior in high school who
is going to do a movie on his video
camera or something you know about rape
and like a fictional story about rape or
something like that
you admire what that kid is trying to do
but there's just that learning curve and
you kind of go I mean I give you credit
for trying and trying to represent but
you're you're just not there you're just
not there yet and the reason I bring
that up is that even though it does kind
of tie into the story uh it does not tie
into what the rest of the movie is doing
when you get to the end of this and you
realize what's going on ask yourself if
that fits in this environment I really
felt it didn't you know it could fit in
another environment ah but even if so
even if they create an environment where
it would work
I felt Shyamalan is just not those
little quirks those little things that
are off a little bits of comedy trying
to make it you know a goofy you know guy
climbing the wall kind of stuff I'm like
this this is not the tone or the movie
to do this in and I just even though
it's not awful it's not laughable or
anything I'm like this does not fit and
I thought that was really distracting I
felt either the ending of this had to be
changed including the twist or her
backstory had to be taken out or that
had to be changed because those two in
my opinion really do not go together so
that was a huge problem for me and I
felt that was really
it was uncomfortable not because of the
subject matter but because the way it
was done and it's just not done by a
person who should be tackling this yet
and and not in this kind of movie in my
opinion but for the rest of the film
like I said it's kind of getting through
those little awkward lines and awkward
moments uh seeing therapists in this I'm
using the trailer to uh should get a
friggin Oscar because she has to say a
lot of these Shyamalan lines and you all
know what I mean by shyamalan lines uh
that are so hard to make sound natural
and flowing and stuff and you know I'm
hearing these lines I'm like if I saw
this written I say you can't save this
no person would say this and like 95% of
what she says I'm like I believe you're
you're really saying this you're not
reading an awkward Shyamalan script but
I know if she didn't say it and someone
else did like some of the other actors
in here I'd be like nah this is this is
awkward so so she's great
McAvoy is great there's a couple other
little things I felt didn't quite work
like I felt like Shyamalan isms up for
example and I I don't think I'm giving
anything away when the kidnapping
happens
um this is a girl in the front seat and
MacAvoy he comes in and he gasses the
other two girls and he's about to drive
away and a turn se sees her in the front
seat and she doesn't leave or anything
she just kind of stays there very slowly
start to put her hand on the handle and
then he gasses her and I'm like did he
not see her did he and I'm thinking oh
like maybe maybe she knows him because
then there's another scene where she
tells one of the girls being taken away
to do something very specific that
that'll cause him to let go and I'm like
okay what she has to know him because
there's just this way to specific and
then you know the face you didn't get
out early and then he didn't do anything
until later like there's some sort of
weird connection and there isn't so
there's kind of no reason for that it's
one of those shaman is is that they
think oh well this is kind of
weird and awkward and odd you know
because that's the world and it's like
now that's just odd you know it's not
odd in the world it's odd in any world
you know so there's little scenes like
that
or like you girls are trapped in
different rooms it's not until something
like days later that they finally say
themselves look and seeking and find
something to get out why would that be
the first thing they say when they're
locked in these rooms so there's all
these little things like that um but
they're not they're not quite too much
for me I compare this very much to the
visit uh you know the visit does have a
lobby's awkward scenes and kind of
awkward writing and stuff but if you can
if you can get through that okay for me
there is definitely a reward at the end
that I thought was very clever um and if
you get to the ending of this and you're
like I don't get it it's okay it's not
anything that's like you're not dumb for
not getting it or you're not oh come on
it's obvious there might be some
information you're not aware of and it
has nothing to do with being cultured or
anything like that when you're done
seeing the movie go home google it just
what was up with the ending of flip what
did that mean and it'll be explained to
you and you'll be like oh and you'll
make the connection so it's like I said
I I can't I can't say it without giving
it away and I'm not going to um your and
I it's hard to see who will get into
this ending and who won't because I know
people who thought this movie was great
and I know people they were just like
bullshit you know at the end kind of
like a lot of channel on twist I know
there's a lot of people that like the
village and I was just like you know I
got the twist even without seeing the
movie um so it's yeah my apologies it's
not something that I can kind of figure
out who would like this twist and who
wouldn't so
I know I've all over the math for the
most part I liked it
it was definitely I think his best shot
movie because there's definitely a style
to it but it's not distracting there's
maybe shots I can think of that I'm like
well that was odd well why was it shot
like that everything else sort of feels
like yeah like any good director we
shoot it this way it's a very
nice-looking film and it's a lot of sort
of traditional Shyamalan shots but
they're done well they're not
distracting they work in the environment
so uh what I recommend it um if you see
the trailer and you're like yeah I think
I might like this you'll enjoy the
majority of it I have no idea what
you're going to think of the ending or
if you'll even get it if you don't get
it honestly do not think you're dumb or
miss something at all I mean really just
go the internet and you'll quickly see
why it didn't get it you know it really
is something where if you look it up
you'll be like oh okay like that I
didn't say anything about me um so it's
a real tough call it is what is better
films uh whatever you think about you
know if you like the film or you don't I
think you can easily say there's a lot
of things in here that do work um and
there are kind of the obvious things
that don't work and if if you were
distracted by the visit if you were
watching it like no that's not natural
no that feels for the end it's really
irking me I'm not able to get into it
this will probably be the same but but
for me it was kind of like the straight
story where it's one of those films I'm
glad I stayed till the end this is why I
try not to walk out of movies there's
very few movies I've ever walked out of
that I went with this anyway but I like
a movie where when you get to the end
like literally the last second can just
change the entire movie um and in such a
way that suddenly makes it from being
bad to good
I like that hot slaw is almost kind of
did that you think it's going to go in a
really dumb stupid direction it's just
like oh my god this is all coming
together and then the straight story did
that too or a straight story we were
like the last minute and same thing with
this I mean it's clear like the last
couple seconds I got you know that's
what's going on so um so I did enjoy it
I did have some major problems with it
but I'm glad I saw it I'm glad it
surprised me and I'm glad it forced me
to look at the film in a totally
different way I I can't for the life of
me predict who will like the ending or
not um it's a real tough call
so let me know below if you like the
ending you know you don't if you can't
don't give it away if if you know you
did see it you know it just any I know
somebody's going to so like I said don't
look at the comments if if you haven't
seen a yen you want to but if you do
just want it ruined right I don't want
to see that film that looks good but go
ahead take a look and then see if other
people liked it because I'm really
curious I'm really curious if people got
into this twist or not uh I did but I
totally understand it somebody else
didn't um so yeah that's about it let me
know what you thought I'm really really
curious about this one I really want to
get further gauge from people that if
they were just like you know do rock
awesome movie or if you're just like
that is the stupidest most dumb a shit
you piece of crap director I'm really
really curious so um yeah that's about
it hopefully I'll get a more V log out
to you sorry then so out of them getting
over a cold and stuff like that so yeah
hopefully more view logs and shows would
be on the way and I shall talk to you
later bye